DAVE MARKS: Welcome
to Talks At Google.
My name's Dave Marks, and
we have a phenomenal event
planned for you today.
We are lucky enough to
have a capella legend Deke
Sharon with us today.
[APPLAUSE]
Deke is, in my opinion,
the most prolific member
of the a capella
community today.
I mean, from his thousands
of arrangements to his work
on NBC's "Sing-Off" and
the "Pitch Perfect" movies,
to his influence over the sound
of modern a capella and all
the a capella music
you hear today,
this is really the man
who started it all.
So please join me in
welcoming Deke Sharon.
[APPLAUSE]
DEKE SHARON: Thank you, guys.
Can you hear me OK?
Am I coming through the stream?
Hello, people sitting at your
desks, pretending to work.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, I thought
I'd come down here
today, partially just because
I want to hang out with you
and get a free lunch.
But also partially
because, in fact,
my brother is working over
at Google X. So hi, Phil.
If you're there in Alameda
and working on something,
you can't tell me or
you'd have to kill me.
I understand that.
And also because over the
course of the past 25 years
when I've been so deeply
involved in the a capella
community, I've learned so
much about life and business
and interaction that I thought
I'd come down here and talk
to you guys about
the different lessons
that a capella has to share with
the world of business at large.
And in fact, special
guest here today,
Googapella, are my
hosts and friends.
And you'll hear a little
bit from them a little bit
later on.
But before that, I want us to
just put this into context.
So when I say a capella,
now, a lot of you guys
probably think, well,
that's just some people
singing pop a capella, right?
Yeah, just getting together,
jamming on awesome tunes.
Fact of the matter is a
capella is the oldest music.
In fact, it's the
oldest creative form
as far as we can tell
because it's existed way
back into prehistoric times.
And if you think about
it, since we are animals,
you look at the animal
kingdom, and you've got whales
and you've got crickets
and you've got birds.
And they all sing together.
They create music
for mating rituals
and all of the other
reasons we, too, sing.
But then something happened
through time, through history.
100 years ago, John Philip
Sousa made a statement
that people laughed
at at the time.
When recorded music
came into predominance,
he said, this is
going to ruin music.
And people thought,
oh, you old Luddite.
That's ridiculous.
I'm sure you guys are
saying "you old Luddite"
all the time here at Google.
But the fact of the matter
he was in fact prophetic
because it changed people's
relation the music.
It used to be if you wanted
to hear music, you made music.
And you think about all
those great classic novels,
after dinner, people get
together in the sitting room
and they sing.
And they made music.
And in fact,
Christmas carols-- it
used to be a community event.
You wanted to hear
Christmas carols,
you made Christmas carols.
But then, recorded
music came around.
And all of a sudden, you
didn't have to do that anymore.
You could put on music
in the background
and fewer people
sang, fewer people
studied music, fewer people had
music as a part of their lives.
And then music started to slip
down the tier of importance
in education.
Pythagoras had it as one of the
five major subjects that people
should study.
And throughout most
of history, music
was a central part of education.
People understood the
importance and the strengthening
of the brain that happened as
a result of studying music.
But it's now a third,
a fourth rate subject.
And it's being slashed
in music budgets
and has been over
the past 20 years--
not just here in California,
but all around the world.
And then you get
television shows
like "American Idol"
that openly mock people
that aren't great at singing.
And the end result
is many people
that I talk to say like,
ah, I'd love to sing.
But I can't sing.
I'm like, what do you
mean you can't sing?
You can talk, you can sing.
No, no, no I'm tone deaf.
I'm like no you're
not tone deaf.
Tone deaf means you cannot
differentiate any pitches.
So someone who is tone
deaf talks like this.
And they'll ask a question,
"are you done with that?"
Like they can't actually
raise their voice
at the end of a sentence.
Every one you've ever
met is not tone deaf.
It's just a matter
of matching pitch.
So you think about it from
a basketball perspective.
If you've never seen
a basketball hoop,
never picked up a basketball
and shot a free throw,
what do you expect your
percentage would be?
Your vocal cords
are just a muscle.
And hitting those notes is
just a matter of repetition.
All of us are able to do it.
But why would you want to do it,
besides the fact that it's fun?
The fact of the matter is there
are many different lessons
that we as individuals have and
take from a capella music that
are really important.
And realize that a capella
is not just singing,
it's singing together.
And I think the singing
together part is really
at the crux of the value of
what I want to talk about today.
So listening.
If you talk to a
marriage counselor,
if you talk to a
therapist, if you
talk to negotiators, people who
focus on conflict resolution,
they all make it very clear the
number one skill that you need
is to be able to listen.
And if you think about it
from our educational system,
what class did you really
learn how to listen in?
I don't know.
I mean you have to be
able to hear when you're
taking lectures or whatever.
But the process of listening,
and one that's active,
is so central to what
we have to be able to do
when we're discussing things.
Once you're singing
in an a capella group,
everything that you do exists
in context of everyone else.
If you sing in perfect
rhythm and in perfect tune
but the rest of the
group has moved,
you're the one that's wrong.
It's a lesson that you learn.
It's endemic to-- Googapella
is laughing over here.
They're like "ha ha
ha, ha ha ha ha."
Yes.
[LAUGHING]
That's the bottom line--
who you are, where you are,
what you're doing,
are you right?
It exists within a
context of other people,
within a sociological context,
within a business framework.
Being able to interact
with other people
requires your knowing where
they are, what they're doing.
And that requires
listening, active listening.
A capella teaches that better
than any other creative form,
better than any other
participatory sport
or whatever that you
can possibly find.
And I just used the
word "teamwork."
And teamwork is absolutely
essential as well.
Individuals are
incredibly powerful.
And we love the story of the
hero, be it Indiana Jones.
Or you watch "American Idol"
and that's the great singer.
But the bottom line is
there's strength in numbers.
And the sum is greater
than the individual parts.
And I'm standing here
on the Google campus.
Corporations exist because
bringing people together
to work on a common cause is
more effective than having
everybody working on their own.
So when you're in
an a capella group,
you begin to understand
the value of teamwork.
You realize how you
guys can work together,
how you fit into this
overall component.
And one of the great
lessons also from a capella
is that if you do it right--
if you do music right,
everyone wins.
So if you think about a
participatory sport, most
of the time, you're
going to lose.
And I say most of
the time because I've
got a good friend in the
Barbershop Harmony Society, who
above his desk has a sign that
says "competitions are mostly
for losers."
Because if you think
about it, I don't
care if it's baseball, if it's
hockey, if it's soccer-- not
basketball, because
Golden State Warriors are
going to win the whole thing.
But in any other sport,
you realize only one person
wins the Super Bowl.
So even if you do
well and you're
above average during
the season, you're
eventually going to lose.
Music's not about losing.
And life is not
necessarily about losing,
or it shouldn't be.
How do you win and win
alongside other people,
alongside your teammates,
alongside your community?
How can you build that
"do no evil" ethos?
A capella is an
amazing way to do this.
And it's incredibly fun
while you're doing it.
So let's see what
else we have here.
There's so much
attention that's been
given to the word diversity
over the past few years--
several years-- in educational
circles, in business circles.
But what does that really mean?
What's the real
value of diversity?
When you sing in an a
capella group, you live it.
The more homogeneous your
group is, the less interesting
they are and the less
they're able to do.
If everybody sings
the same voice part,
you've got a very
narrow bandwidth
within which you're
able to do anything.
When you've got high
tenors and low basses,
when you've got a beat
boxer, when you've
got gorgeous ballad
singing sopranos
and raspy soulful
altos, you've got
an incredible a capella group.
The diversity is what creates
the boundaries within which
you're able to do anything.
And that's something
that you live.
One of my favorite things
about college a capella
is that a college
a capella group
is the most diverse gathering
of people on a college campus.
You've got your sports teams.
You've got your
sci-fi nerd clubs.
You've got your fraternities.
But in a college
a capella group,
people are drawn from all
of those different circles--
and the theater person, and
the goth, et cetera, et cetera.
You end up with--
you're laughing.
You've got your own goths
in Googapella as well.
But you end up with an
incredibly diverse selection
of people.
And when I sang in
the Tufts Beelzebubs,
I made lifelong
friends with people
that I would've passed
in four years of college
and never even said hello to.
I never would have
crossed paths with them
possibly, except maybe
in the dining hall.
That bringing together
of different people--
learning how to
interact with them,
learning how to listen
with them, from them,
and create alongside them--
is incredibly valuable.
And then you never have to ask
the question, why diversity?
Why do I care that I would want
someone different from myself?
Because you realize
you need them.
And that you are
stronger for them.
And your own strengths
are amplified with them
right there beside you.
So let's see what else.
A capella is just people.
So when you go see
a rock concert,
you've got these flame pots
and giant screens and people
are playing electric
guitars and synthesizers,
and there's computer banks.
When it's a capella, it's
just you and your friends.
And everything that happens--
every emotion, every mood,
every sound, every
movement, every feeling
that the audience feels
comes entirely from you.
There's this incredible
sense of self-reliance.
And obviously, I know
you guys down here,
you start new initiatives.
Like how are we going to
make something happen?
Like it's just
we've got this idea
and where do you go from there?
A capella is all
about that every time.
We've got this song
we want to sing.
What are we going to do?
You have to do it yourselves.
Learning how to rely
entirely upon yourselves
is one of the great lessons
you learn from a capella.
And it's a beautiful
thing when you finally
bring a song to life with just
yourself and your friends.
And you could do it anywhere.
You can do on the radio.
You could do it at midnight
at a friend's birthday party.
It's a good feeling.
So how many of you
guys have heard
of the Dunning-Kruger effect?
Nice.
You're all
over-educated down here.
I love it.
Well, I hope I don't
get this wrong.
But a good deal of research
has been done of late
to try to figure out where is
that line between competence
and incompetence.
And it seems as
though we're learning
that people who are
incompetent don't actually
know that they're incompetent.
And people can take a test
with a bunch of other people,
and the vast majority of
them believe that they
are in the upper tier.
It's definitely the case
with driving, right?
I came down from
San Francisco today.
And I'll guarantee you that
most people on that road
were sure that they were one
of the best drivers on them.
And not all of them were.
Mathematically, it's impossible.
And I could tell you the
license plate numbers
of the ones who were the worst.
[LAUGHING]
The bottom line is, people need
constant, immediate feedback
in a positive way to
begin to realize how
they exist in this framework.
And I can even think
of certain people
who were in different
fields that effect us all,
such as politics, who
would have benefited
from a lifetime of
hearing from other people
ways in which
they're not actually
doing a good job at
the things they think
they're doing a good job at.
This feedback loop exists
within an a capella rehearsal
constantly.
You're in a section,
and you hear your part.
Am I in tune with
the other people?
Am I out of tune?
Am I in rhythm with them?
Am I out of rhythm?
You're getting this feedback
from the music director--
speed this up, slow it down,
tune this down a little bit.
A lot of it is not just
knowing that you need
to change these little things.
It's realizing that
it's OK to be imprecise.
The only way you get better is
through that constant feedback
loop.
And so often in
businesses, my wife,
who is a business consultant
and works within human resources
and making better teams and
training high-level management
to be great at
what they're doing,
so often she talks to leaders
who are stuck in a position
to have to fire somebody
who's incompetent.
And they've been in the job
for three and a half years.
And no one has ever
actually told them
that they weren't
doing a good job.
That's doesn't happen
in a capella, right?
You know you're not doing a
good job in the first 30 seconds
of rehearsal.
And I say it with a smile on
my face because in a capella,
it's OK.
You're going to be making
mistakes constantly.
The human voice is a
fretless instrument.
You're able to slide
all over the map.
You have good days.
You have bad days.
And all of you together are used
to making mistakes together,
and to learning how to be
better at all of the thing
that you need to be better at.
And here, you're great at
this and you're usually great.
But today, you're
having a bad day.
Down here, you're
usually struggling,
and you're making big strides.
That feedback loop is one
of the most powerful things
that people can learn, which is
one of the reasons why I feel
like we need to continue to
have this kind of vocal music
in schools so students
can learn what it's
like to be with others,
to make mistakes,
and get that immediate feedback.
Let's see what else.
So all of this has
been about the group.
But what about you?
When you're in an
a capella group,
you start to get a clear
picture of who you are.
What's your role?
What are your strengths?
What are you able to do well?
And people often ask me,
well, what solo could I sing?
How do I fit in?
There are all these great
other people in the group.
Where's my voice?
There is a great song
for everyone to sing.
The Randy Newmans in the
world and the Tom Waits
and the Bob Dylans, right?
Even the guys with
this voice, right?
There's a great song
for you out there.
There's an incredible
body of work
that's been created
throughout humankind.
And you have something
inside of you
that's incredibly beautiful.
You have a song to sing.
And when you're in an a capella
group, you learn what that is.
And that's a great feeling.
We all have value.
And I know this feels
like a very '70s thing.
Yeah, I'm a child of the '70s,
northern California hippie.
But that's an important lesson.
Maybe the millennials that
are getting teased too
often learned the lesson
that everybody's great.
Not everybody's
great at everything.
That's a lesson
that is absolutely
detrimental to society.
But finding out how you're great
and what you can give-- that's
the real gift.
And that's one of the things
that a capella definitely
can give you.
And then there are just
straightforward things
that we all need in life.
We need health.
We need happiness.
We need friends.
We need endorphins and oxytocin
and all the great chemicals
that our bodies
produce for us when
we have positive experiences.
There has been study after
study by Chorus America
and the American Choral
Directors Association
and our educational
circles that show
how we, when we're
creating something
alongside other
people, feel happiness.
When we sing, we feel happiness.
The natural rhythms of our body
in alignment with other people,
it lowers our stress level.
It brings joy into our lives.
And this is something
that's very clear.
You can read articles out
there by Brian Eno who
has a life of creating music.
And what he decided he needed
more than anything else
in his life is to join a choir.
Because when he sings
alongside other people,
it brings him more joy than
any other creative pursuit
that he's done.
So that's another
important part of it.
And then there are
social benefits as well.
There's so many people who
are sitting in their cubicle--
like you guys right
now watching this--
who are working, in many cases,
alone or on a small team.
And they don't feel
as though they're
interacting with other
people, particularly
people who are very
different from themselves.
And the great thing about
a group like Googapella,
here at this
wonderful company, is
that you have people across
all strata of the organization,
right?
Including one of the members
who's the massage therapist,
is that right?
Still?
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
DEKE SHARON: Yes, exactly!
But what I'm saying is
you sing in this group,
you get to understand and make
friends with and spend time
with people across the entirety
of this enormous organization--
not just your little team.
And you'll make
friends, fall in love,
make little Google a capella
babies-- I don't know.
You guys-- that's
the next step, there.
And I'm sure they'll
be wonderful and bright
and have four-colored
little baby jumper
outfits, and the whole thing.
But the social benefits
are very clear from singing
in an a capella group.
And again, like I said, if you
do it right, you'll always win.
So that's all nice.
But then what's the
value to the business?
People are working hard.
There are long hours.
People are drained.
But Googapella's not drained.
You guys go to rehearsal
of your own volition.
You want to spend more time
with other people here.
This recharges your
batteries, right?
There's a joy that you
feel when you sing.
And then you're recharged.
My daughter goes to a performing
arts school called Adda
Clevenger up in San Francisco.
And their educational model's
very different from what
I've found anywhere else.
And she loves it.
What happens is they
all get together
at the beginning of the day
and they all sing music.
And then they break
up each grade.
And they have math,
they have English,
and then you have theater.
And then you've got science.
And then you've got history.
And then you've got dance.
Then you've got
creative expression.
And by going back and exercising
different parts of your body
and your mind and your creative
spirit throughout the day,
this kind of cross
training as it were
allows for a much
greater experience.
And then you're refreshed.
You're not sitting in a desk the
whole day doing the same thing.
So join Googapella, OK?
I know they've got
a waiting list.
They need tenors, though,
is my understanding.
Tenors.
No?
You've got your tenors?
They're all set.
They don't want you.
Stay in your seat.
They're fine.
Start another group.
Oogapella.
I think you could be part
two of the whole thing.
But there are definite
benefits to a company.
And I hope that other companies
find out and learn about this.
Obviously, the
Techapella concert
with eight different groups
this past November was amazing.
And now there are a
bunch of other groups
that have gotten
started, that want
to join the Techapella concert.
And they gotta get on
that list, don't they?
Yeah.
We'll see if there's room
for you this next year.
But this is beautiful thing.
One of my mottos for life is to
spread harmony through harmony.
And another one is to
sing through your life.
And people sing through
school and they sing
in college a capella groups.
And they love it.
And then it just ends for them.
And that's the end of
their creative expression.
Having this be a part
of a company that's
so much a part of
your lives reinforces
the power and the strength,
the value that a company can
have beyond just a paycheck.
It's a circle of friends.
It's an opportunity for
creative expression.
And it's a family in a real way.
And they're nodding.
Yes it's a family.
It's not like, Yeah, we know
we're supposed to nod now.
No, it changes your relationship
with what's going on.
And there's great value to a
business to have that there.
So my vision is that these
kind of casual a capella groups
will start to spring up
in companies all around.
100 years ago, people
would get together
with their company,
General Motors or whatever,
and sing company songs.
And I mean it was
a kind of a thing.
And people would be
employed by the same company
for their whole life.
And there was a lot less
stress in society back then.
You were a company man
and you felt like you
were a part of this company.
Obviously our
society has changed.
But with more groups like
this within businesses,
the different values and
the different benefits
that can come from a capella can
belong to that company as well.
And the members of the
group will definitely
feel more valued and
more connected to what's
going on within the business.
And once again, guys here
at Google, you get to say,
we did it first.
So that's that.
Sing.
That's what I'm telling you do.
And hopefully some
of you guys out
there will take this to heart.
And if there's anything
I can do to help
you do that, dekesharon.com.
I will get you singing.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE MARKS: So Deke, to start.
I mean as of now, you are an
a capella legend and really
a standard of the community.
But you kind of have carved
this role for yourself.
For people who aren't as
familiar with your background,
can you tell them about
how this opportunity
came to be and your growth
since the Beezlebubs?
DEKE SHARON: Yeah.
Well it wasn't an opportunity.
It was just a crazy dream.
Basically, when I was
music director of the Tufts
Beezlebubs, I wanted to
sing the kind of music
that was on the radio.
So long story short,
I started integrating
beat boxing and different
vocal instrumental sounds
and turned what was very
much a four-part harmony
style into a 14 person group
who would do 14-part harmony.
And you'd sing the
kind of crazy songs
on the radio that back then
were impossible to do--
Peter Gabriel and Led Zeppelin
and U2 and Pink Floyd.
I mean, back then, it was all
shooby doo wop, Billy Joel,
and Crosby, Stills, and Nash.
All great, but there was
a thing to be unlocked.
And when you look
at music history,
throughout music
history, there's
been a capella-- sea shanties,
and madrigals, and barbershop,
and doo-wop.
So what we're doing now
isn't different fundamentally
from a cultural standpoint.
It's just different,
technically.
So when I graduated,
I was like I
feel like I have
lightning in a bottle.
If people only knew what
this was, they would love it.
And everyone, including my
high school choral director,
laughed at me.
He likened it to tiddlywinks.
He literally told
people, this guy
wants to create a career of
this college a capella thing
that he's doing.
And he's like, I want to
create a career of tiddlywinks.
Like we'll have tiddlywink
networks and tiddlywink
societies and
tiddlywink competitions.
He's like I feel bad for him.
And now he's like,
OK, you were wrong.
It worked out.
So yeah.
It's just been a lifetime of
following this crazy dream
and wanting to help more
people sing and spread
this kind of music,
both from the bottom up
and create more groups,
and also from the top down
through the media.
Get more people singing
the way the has happened
throughout human history.
DAVE MARKS: And getting back to
that modern sound of a capella
because people who haven't
listened to old a capella
might not realize
that it doesn't always
sound like we hear it on "Pitch
Perfect," like it does today.
And you were a big
influence in that.
Can you tell me
about the evolution
from the doo-wop,
shooby doo wops
into the amazing [INAUDIBLE]
voice as instruments.
DEKE SHARON: So when I was
in the Tufts Beezlebubs,
I just wanted every
woman in the audience
to love us-- and
particularly me.
Because that's
really what college
a capella is all about it.
It's a giant, campus-wide
mating ritual.
And at Tufts, the
Beezlebubs were
like rock stars on the campus.
So like, you already felt there
was an importance to what you
were doing.
And I was, at the same time,
at New England Conservatory
of Music in Boston.
And I went by Tower Records back
and forth several times a week.
And I would stop
at Tower Records
when the new
billboard charts wall
was posted because I
wanted to sing a song that
was going up the charts.
So I'd stop by on Tuesday,
find out what that song was,
arrange it, teach it
to the group Wednesday
and Thursday night.
And then Friday and
Saturday night, we'd
sing it that weekend.
And I know, I was crazy.
Yeah, totally.
I went to class sometimes,
too-- underlined sometimes.
I like to say I went to
Beezlebubs University.
Anyway, there were so
many songs that you just
couldn't make work
like Duran Duran
that people were
loving and listening
to all the time on college
rock radio stations.
And yet everything was
still "The Longest Time"
and shooby doo wop,
as you were saying.
So there was a song in a movie,
boom box above John Cusack's
head.
And I was like this--
every woman in the audience
will melt if we could possibly
sing "In Your Eyes" by Peter
Gabriel.
So I went back to my dorm room.
And I started listening to it.
And I heard all these talking
drums like, do do do do,
all these shakers and stuff.
And I was like you
can't shooby doo
wop your way through this song.
So I took out a big piece
of orchestral music paper
and I just started jotting
down the different parts
that I heard.
And I ended up
bringing an arrangement
into the group that was like
12 different vocal parts.
And they looked at me
like, dude, what is this?
I was like, just trust me.
Just make these sounds
and do this thing.
And they're like, you
get a half an hour.
That's it.
Anyway, by the end of rehearsal,
they're like, all right.
We'll try it this
weekend at the concert.
I think it was up in Maine.
And it was one of
those moments when
we were done singing
the song that-- it's
like the end of a movie.
There's this silence
from the audience.
And then all of a sudden-- rah!
This giant wave
of energy came up.
And I realized like, whoa!
So I started dabbling
in this more.
And we were trying
to figure out how
to do vocal percussion
with our voices
and use the voices
as instruments,
and just really repositioning
what collegiate a capella could
be.
And yeah.
It was a crazy year.
And from there,
I was like, yeah,
I'm going to keep
doing this thing.
And even the guys I graduated
with, were like, dude,
you're nuts.
That's never going to happen.
And back then, there were maybe
200 college a capella groups.
Now we've got 3,000.
And I wanted to create a
March Madness of a capella
so people would know about this.
So I created the NCCA,
the National Championship
of College A Capella,
which is now international.
So it's the ICCA.
And that's a real competition.
And then it's in
"Pitch Perfect."
So yeah.
There's a lot a luck involved
for anybody who's wondering.
DAVE MARKS: So if someone were
to do the same exercise you did
it, of look for a song
that was rising the charts
and try to arrange it
by the weekend, in 2016,
they might find it full of
electronic dance music or maybe
some trap rap type things.
What kind of impact do you think
that'll make on the a capella
community?
DEKE SHARON: So if you look
at all the other styles
of a capella, think
about doo-wop,
think about barbershop--
these were very popular
for a period of time.
And then they disappeared.
My great hope for the
future of a capella
is that these high
school and college
groups are doing exactly
what you're talking about.
Pentatonix, biggest a capella
group out there right now.
When they were on
the "Sing-Off,"
they were developing
their own sound.
And it was working
with them each week.
And they started to
integrate dubstep and EDM,
electronic dance music
sounds, and dropping the bass,
and all this kind
of stuff that really
wasn't happening in a capella.
And now it's a full
part of their sound.
And they're super cutting edge.
And three years from
now, five years from now,
there'll be some new like
reggae with laser blasts in it.
Or some sound that we
don't know what it is.
But there's going to be an
eager music director who's
going to take and figure
out how to do that vocally,
weave it into their sound.
And hopefully,
unlike in the past,
the style and the sound
of contemporary a capella
will continue to remain
on the cutting edge.
And people will still
have classical music
and barbershop and doo-wop and
the sound that we have now.
It'll all continue
and co-exist, which
is why I call it
contemporary a capella.
Because it's all being
done at the same time, now.
DAVE MARKS: So I'd
like to jump over
to your involvement
in the "Pitch Perfect"
movies a little bit.
So you served as music director
for the "Pitch Perfect" movies,
right?
DEKE SHARON: Yeah.
Actually, my understanding is
the Directors Guild of America
controls the word "director."
So you can't have a music
director on a movie.
So I am technically
vocal producer.
Yeah.
And I taught the
arrangements, the actresses,
and all that kind of stuff.
DAVE MARKS: Could you walk
us through a little bit more
of your responsibilities on
the project, what a day at work
looked like?
DEKE SHARON: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well there was a lot a lost
sleep the first time around.
Because it was like,
these actresses
have never sung a capella.
Are we going to actually
be able to have a movie?
But basically, what happens
is early on in the process,
we have something called
a capella boot camp, which
every day, they all get together
and I do big group rehearsals
as well as one-on-one
rehearsals with all the actors
and actresses.
And they're also in
choreographic rehearsal
with AJ, who is an
amazing choreographer,
works with Usher, et cetera.
And they basically sing and
dance and sing and dance
and sing and dance
till they're really
able to do this on their own.
Once they were able to
sing their part alone,
for me, pretty much
from memory, I'll
send them into a
recording studio
we've built right there
in the production offices.
And they record their own
part all the way through.
And then the reason
they need it memorized
is they'll be lip syncing
to themselves on set.
So the early part
of the process is
a lot of sleepless
nights and hard work,
and let's adjust
this arrangement.
I've got to make sure
she's up to speed on this.
And then the latter
part is a lot
of sitting outside
in an August night,
sticky from dusk
till dawn, watching
a bunch of actresses
lip sync their parts
over and over while
they're dancing.
And then going up
on stage and saying,
Brittany, remember you
don't have the melody there.
You gotta go wah
zing zing zing zing.
She's like, oh,
right, right, right.
Sorry, sorry,
sorry, And then, OK!
Let's do it again!
And so yeah.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's like
really creative.
And other times
it's like-- Yeah.
Lip sync patrol.
But whatever it takes
to make the movie.
DAVE MARKS: So I
only have one more.
So if you want to start lining
up for audience questions,
we're going to pitch
those in a second.
Otherwise, I'll keep making
them up as I go along.
But I'd say, what's
next for Deke Sharon?
What can we see
coming out of you?
What are you most excited about?
DEKE SHARON: Well, I've got
a national theatrical touring
show called "Vocalosity"
that's going back on the road.
And it'll be coming out
to the west coast, which
is really great to be in
performing arts centers.
And the thesis of the
show-- although I never say
it and never have
the singer say it--
is to try to convince more
people to bring singing back
into their own lives.
There's a great musical
that I did the arrangements
for called "In Transit" that
was written in part by Christian
Andersen Lopez, who was half
of the song writing team that
wrote "Frozen," and her husband
Bobby Lopez who did "Avenue Q"
and "Book of Mormon."
They are like royalty
on Broadway, right now.
So we have everything.
We have funding.
We're just waiting for a
house to open on Broadway.
That's one of the
big challenges.
So Broadway is soon
to be coming next.
And there's a whole
new program I've
created called the Contemporary
A Capella League, which
basically is to create
after-work groups,
kind of like Googapella, where
people from an entire community
can get together and
sing casually once a week
and make friends
and fall in love
and keep music a
part of their lives.
DAVE MARKS: Great.
DEKE SHARON: And
the other things,
it's like Google X.
I could tell you,
but then I'd have to kill you.
DAVE MARKS: Sounds fair.
We'll stay tuned.
DEKE SHARON: Yeah
DAVE MARKS: Kiana?
AUDIENCE: It's good
to see you, again.
DEKE SHARON: Hey,
how are you doing?
AUDIENCE: I'm good,
doing really well.
First, I have to say I totally--
everything you're saying today
was extremely resonant.
Like I was like, yes, yes.
And I have to say like,
I did college a capella.
And I was in a group called
Talisman out of Stanford.
You might have heard of them.
I think--
DEKE SHARON: I've gotta
cut you off right there.
Because Stanford
Talisman, in my opinion,
is the single greatest
ICCA set I've ever seen.
OK.
This is this mid-- Oh no!
I'm not making this up.
In the mid '90s,
all these groups
were going out on
the final stage.
And back then, we had
it at Carnegie Hall.
And they went out on the stage,
and they sang and they danced.
They moved around, all
this kind of stuff.
And then Stanford
Talisman came out.
And they stood in a big arc.
And they made everybody
else look like children.
They sang songs from
the African diaspora.
They got the entire
audience just melting.
And there was so much purity,
so much harmony, so much heart
in their music that they
were runaway favorites.
And there's a little
piece of me that
hopes that the college
a capella world
realizes that not everything
needs to be "Glee."
Not everything needs
to be pop, pop, pop.
But there's a lot
of amazing music
happening all around the world.
And when you draw on
it as an inspiration,
you're able to take things
up to the next level.
So yeah.
So that's Standford Talisman.
AUDIENCE: So when
you saw all that,
you obviously know how
that has worked in my life
and what a wonderful privilege
that was to be a part of that.
Like crazy to this day.
We're actually all getting
together next weekend,
and it's going to be ridiculous.
But I say all that
to say, you spent
a lot of time talking about
getting people together
to sing.
And I'd like to ask you, I
know you're with these people
all the time.
And I know you're singing and
interacting with music all
the time.
But when do you get to
sing with your friends
and just be Deke on
the tenor part 1?
DEKE SHARON: Well,
the fact of the matter
is, I created a group 25 years
ago called the House Jacks.
And I love being on
stage and performing.
And we've toured
around the world.
And we were the first group
with the designated beat boxer
and to push the sound into
the contemporary realm,
into the professional realm.
But last year, because
I'm so busy with movies
and television, and
I was on Lifetime
or whatever, I had to hand in
my pitch pipe and basically say,
guys you go on without me.
I'm still getting an
opportunity to perform.
I performed with you
guys at Carnegie Hall
a couple months ago.
That was pretty awesome!
Yeah.
And I was just back
a couple days ago
with Highlands Voices and Stay
Tuned in northern New Jersey
at a wonderful festival where
I sang a couple songs of them.
So I'm still getting up
on stage and I'm singing.
But I really feel
like what I need
to do right now is be
that elder statesman
and get up in front of people.
And sometimes I'm directing
or sometimes I'm talking.
And I'm not always the
one doing the singing.
But I'll keep singing
through there, too.
Thank you for asking that.
AUDIENCE: So Deke, thanks.
I also sang college a capella
and had the great opportunity
to sing at the
finals of the ICCA.
DEKE SHARON: Oh, great!
What group?
AUDIENCE: Cornell Last Call.
DEKE SHARON: Nice group.
Yeah, yeah.
Great.
AUDIENCE: I won't
say how long ago,
because I don't want to give
away my age-- way, way too long
ago.
So first of all,
thank you so much.
That was one of the incredible
experiences of my life.
And so I want to say, first
of all, thank you for that.
But you also talked a lot about
how basically everyone can find
a voice and be able to sing.
Given the competitive nature
of a capella and taking it
to competitions like
the ICCAs, and even
just the competitive nature
of getting into a group
to begin with in colleges,
what would be your advice
and guidance for those who
may not have the opportunity
to sing with some of
those elite groups
that go on to do all
the various things?
DEKE SHARON: Totally.
Well, the great thing is that
within the collegiate a capella
world, for instance, there are
3,000 plus groups out there.
Only 300 are doing the ICCA.
So bottom line, you've got
90% of them are not competing.
They're just in the group
to sing and make friends
and fall in love
and go on road trips
and do all the great things.
And when I was in the
Beelzebubs, we never competed.
It was actually
part of our mantra.
We were like, we don't
ever want to compete.
Music shouldn't be
about competition.
And honestly, I didn't start
the ICCA because I wanted people
to compete.
I did it entirely
for the audience,
to create a March Madness.
And every time I'm backstage,
I go to all the singers,
and I'm like, guys,
these your friends.
You want them to be great.
We want to spread
all this music.
And you're here,
you already won.
And that's what I told people
on the "Sing Off" as well.
And the great thing that's
happening on college campuses
is if these elite
groups are already full,
more groups are getting started.
And more and more-- I'll bet
you if you went back to Cornell,
you'd be like, I can't believe
how many a capella groups there
are now.
And at some schools
like Yale that
don't have fraternities
and sororities,
they have like 20
a capella groups.
Yeah, I know, totally.
And people are like, really?
Yale?
They're so busy studying.
You guys work at Google and you
have time to sing a capella,
OK.
There's time in your lives.
You can make time for it.
And it actually makes everything
else easier and more fun
and recharges your batteries.
So the beautiful thing is
I'd say only a small portion
of what's going
on in contemporary
a capella involves competition.
And for most of the people,
it's just happiness and joy
and love.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEKE SHARON: Thank you
for that great question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Deke.
Thanks so much for coming.
DEKE SHARON: Of course.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned earlier
that a lot of what
drew you to a capella
is the ability to be completely
creative and innovative
with your sound.
So would you mind either
demonstrating or perhaps
teaching the audience
here today one
of your favorite or most
innovative or creative sounds
that you've explored?
DEKE SHARON: Oh, wow.
OK.
You want the trumpet?
OK, I'll teach trumpet.
But first, so that you guys
know what I'm talking about.
So there are so many
different instrumental sounds
you can make with your voice.
You could do a
regular trumpet like--
[MAKING A TRUMPET SOUND]
Like a trombone
[MAKING A TROMBONE SOUND]
Or a flute
[MAKING  A FLUTE SOUND]
or like an electric guitar
[MAKING AN ELECTRIC GUITAR
SOUND]
But what they want is--
[LAUGHING]
They want the muted-- I know.
It's amazing that it's
a marketable skill, now.
What they want is the
muted trumpet which
sounds a little like this--
[MAKING A MUTED TRUMPET SOUND]
--which is both
occasionally useful
from a musical standpoint, and
also if you're on long drives.
You can get whatever you want
if you're in the backseat.
You're just like--
[MAKING MUTED TRUMPET SOUND]
OK, fine!
We'll change the radio.
[LAUGHING]
So the best way I
can teach this sound
is actually what I
call Cartman method.
How many of you guys are
familiar with "South Park?"
right?
OK.
So you know (MIMICKING
CARTMAN FROM "SOUTH PARK")
Cartman talks like this.
He down here.
He says like, "hey guys."
He'll say, "hey guys."
AUDIENCE: (MIMICKING
CARTMAN) Hey, guys.
DEKE SHARON: He's like,
I want my cheesy poofs.
AUDIENCE: I want
my cheesy poofs.
DEKE SHARON: And then
he gets excited, he's
like (RAISING VOICE
PITCH) oh my God!
AUDIENCE: Oh my God!
DEKE SHARON: (RAISING VOICE
PITCH AGAIN) Oh my God!
AUDIENCE: Oh my God!
DEKE SHARON: Aah!
AUDIENCE: Aah!
DEKE SHARON: So
keep that ugly tone.
And then you take
that "aah" and then
you're going to close
your mouth around it.
So listen.
[SOUND EFFECT] Try that.
[AUDIENCE REPEATS NOISE]
DEKE SHARON: Did you hear
how that just got pretty,
all you singers over here?
You were like, aah!
And then I was like
go [SOUND EFFECT].
And you went [SOUND EFFECT].
No, you have to lose all of
the beauty in your voice.
You have to keep
that kind of noise.
So keep the [SOUND EFFECTS].
DEKE SHARON: You're
getting there.
And I've got a YouTube channel
with all these different
instrumental sound little
videos et cetera, et cetera.
And if you come up with
an instrumental sound
and teach me how to do
it-- because it's not
like there's a school you can
go to for annoying vocal noises.
We're deriving this.
This is a new, cutting
edge technology.
So if you want to start a
new team at Google for that,
let me know.
And I won't tell anyone.
Let's keep it secret.
We'll keep it secret.
Awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you have
someone who isn't a singer
or isn't a professional
singer and they've
seen professional
singers or maybe they've
memorized sort of,
but not really.
And they've never actually
memorized a piece.
They've had the experience over
and over again of thinking,
I couldn't do that
or I can't do that.
How do you take that
person and motivate
them to reach their next level?
DEKE SHARON: So I mentioned
a basketball analogy earlier.
And I want to take
it one step further .
So we watch Steph
Curry and the Warriors
break records and play
amazing team basketball
at the next level.
And if you get too focused on
what he's doing, you may think,
I should never play basketball.
He's too good.
You may watch Prince
sing and be like,
I got no business doing that.
But that's ridiculous if only
the greatest chefs cooked,
we'd all starve to death.
So the proficiency of the
experts should in no way
inform the rest of us as
to our ability to do it.
Moreover, if you're driving
on a Sunday afternoon
past a high school,
basketball hoops outside,
and you see some 35,
40-year-old shooting hoops.
You don't think anything of it.
You're like, oh, they're
having a good time.
But you go to the
farmer's market
and you hear some 35,
40-year-old singing
and you probably immediately
start judging them.
Ooh, I don't know if that's
so great, or whatever.
That's something that's
broken our society.
We are too critical of
the arts, particularly
from a participatory standpoint.
And part of what I want to do
is change that dialogue we have.
I cannot tell you how I'm
happy I am that "American Idol"
is off the air.
Because I think they've
done enormous psychic damage
to people who now only sing
in their car or in the shower
or maybe once a yea
karaoke when they're drunk.
Like they're
terrified that they're
going to be called out
for not being great.
So I think we just need
to remind them, everybody,
that OK, you're
not to be Picasso,
but that doesn't mean you should
never jot down a line drawing.
And you're never going
to be Thomas Keller,
so that doesn't mean you
shouldn't cook dinner
for your friends.
You're not going to be
Pentatonix, but singing is fun.
And you should sing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DEKE SHARON: And
then if they don't
do that, punch them and drag
them to your next rehearsal.
And when they wake up you've,
got them chained to the chair.
And they don't get
to leave until they
sing a perfect major third.
AUDIENCE: Great.
DEKE SHARON: Good luck.
Let me know how it goes.
And I'll testify at
trial, if I need to.
I'm happy to.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Deke.
So I had a question for you.
Now when you mentioned the
voice is of fretless instrument.
And I was curious,
how much when you're
doing this kind of
arranging, how much do
you think of the
way chords sound
like when you're
not forced to have
equal temperament, for
example, versus what you can
do with the voice and
the kinds of harmonics
that you can use
effectively in vocal harmony
DEKE SHARON: I'm about to
get super music theory wonky.
I hope I don't lose
you guys-- especially,
those of you watching
the Google Tech Talk.
They just went, click.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry!
DEKE SHARON: No, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
No.
OK.
So basically the bottom
line is the human voice
creates sound that
exists within physics.
And we are able
to sing in better
tune than a piano or a
guitar because they're really
locked to this well-tempered
tuning system that
is fundamentally imperfect.
We made this trade
off so that then we
could have harmonic changes.
Otherwise, what you get is
like Indian classical music,
which remains in the same key,
the same mode, the same raga
the whole time.
And you can have a
melody, but you don't
have any harmonic changes.
Those are your two options.
So I think it's a good trade,
but it's still imperfect
The one thing I really do
think about when I'm arranging
is keeping the voices
spread very much
the way that exists in the
physics of sound, the harmonic
series.
You can look it up
online, Wikipedia.
I'm sure Google has their own
several pages somewhere online
of the harmonic
series and the way
that every note casts a
number of harmonics above it.
To make a long story
short, it means
keeping your bass notes low and
your other voices closer voiced
up above.
Because what that does is it
allows you to tune more easily.
And what I try to do
in my arrangements,
as much as there's a lot of joy
in them and a lot of complexity
is to make it easy for people
to do things like tune,
so then they can focus on
connecting with an audience
and emoting rather than spending
their entire time having
to worry about the mechanics
of what's going on.
So that's really my go to.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEKE SHARON: No problem.
And you can come back now.
Click.
Unmute.
OK, good.
You're back.
AUDIENCE: It's funny just as an
aside that you mentioned that.
Because in Georgian
singing, their scale
is based on the fifth.
And their octaves are,
therefore, out of tune.
So they can't have deep bases.
They have to keep
everything within about
an octave and a half, or
else they're out of tune.
DEKE SHARON: Wow.
That's Georgia over in Russia.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, not
where the peaches are.
DEKE SHARON: Nah, I called
United Airlines once.
And I needed a
flight to Georgia.
And they're like, it's
going to be very expensive.
And I was like, no, I want
the one here in the US.
AUDIENCE: Anyway, I've been
directing a community course
for about 20 years,
focusing mostly
on world music and
traditional music.
And I liked the comments
you made about Talisman.
And I've just been
thinking about--
as you were speaking about all
these things-- and the element
that I really pay a lot of
attention to that was sort
of missing from what
you're talking about
was the cultural element.
Because I really focus on
music that comes from places.
And I think that in
addition to everything
you said, one of the
things about doing
that is that you're
bringing a sense of place
and a sense of culture into
play, into people, and both
the singers and the audience.
And I think that's
really important.
And I see-- well,
"American Idol" especially.
But a lot of modern music
that's very pop-oriented
is great in its own ways.
But we're losing a
little bit of sense
of that global connectedness.
And groups like Vocal
Sampling and groups
like what Keith Terry's doing
and lots of those groups
try to get there.
But it's hard for Americans
to hear that stuff
and be aware of it.
DEKE SHARON: Well, one of the
great things about a capella
is once people fall in love with
the sound of the human voice,
they're much more likely to move
into different styles of music.
In fact, singers are able
to blend styles more easily
than other styles of music.
So you go to a King's
Singer's concert
and they start out
singing early music.
And then they go into
20th century classical.
And they may sing some
classical choral music.
And then they go and they
sing some early folk Americana
and maybe some jazz
and end with some pop.
No instrumentalist
could do that.
Because they'd need like
early music instruments
like recorders and sackbuts.
And then they'd need an
entire string orchestra.
And then they'd need some
world music instruments
and a jazz combo
and a rock band.
Like it's never done.
So you're able to
travel around the world
more effectively with
your voice than you
are with any other
style of music--
or any other instrumentation,
more correctly.
And the beautiful thing about
what's going on in a capella
now-- and you may not see this
with Pentatonix or on YouTube.
But the fact of the matter is
different styles of a capella
are becoming more popular
based on their local roots.
So you go to Taiwan which
has a tremendous tradition
of a capella singing.
And you get a group
like O-Kai Singers who
are blending Taiwanese pop music
with this traditional Taiwanese
style.
Or when I made the
"Sing-Off" in China,
we were taking Chinese songs
and blending them with popular
idioms.
So you'd get some old
Maoist song with disco beat.
We just had a lot of
fun being really crazy
and creating a new sound and
style of contemporary Chinese
a capella.
And for anybody who's
in America thinking
like, well, but everything's
homogenized here.
There's no real sense of place.
I tell you, so little has been
done and so much still exists.
First of all, where's the
great Hawaiian a capella group?
Where's the great Cajun
a capella group, right?
We just, on the "Sing-Off,"
created the first ever country
a capella group with Home Free.
There's a vast--
where's the great Latin
a capella that's
going to tear up-- I
was hoping Nota would do that.
And Vocal Sampling
from Cuba's tremendous.
But there's still so
much, so many stones
we that haven't been uncovered.
Plus you can blend
these different styles.
Take Six took gospel
melodies, jazz harmonies,
R&B stylings and created a
style that's all their own.
And now they've got dozens
of Grammys as a result of it.
Within a capella, there
are so many frontiers that
haven't even been bridged yet.
So keep pushing.
And do look for location.
And do listen for to great
Bulgarian women's choir
tradition that happens over--
the Le Mystere des Voix
Bulgares.
I almost did a
Bulgarian Fulbright
before I was like,
nah, I'm gonna
do this pop thing, because I
just love that sound so much.
And oh, there amazing singing
going on down in Australia
and Sri Lanka-- like
all around the world.
So look for that.
And you'll find it.
Thank you for bringing that up.
DAVE MARKS: All
right, let's hear it
one more time for Deke Sharon!
DEKE SHARON: Thank you, guys!
[APPLAUSE]